scientists have hailed a powerful new
combination of drugs which has been
described as a once-in-a-generation
advanced for cancer treatment the drugs
which use the body's own immune system
to attack cancerous cells shrunk more
than half of patients advanced melanoma
tumors but as our health correspondent
thomas moore explains the treatment
won't be cheap once melanoma skin cancer
begins to spread the outlook for most
patients is poor but pam smith cancer is
on the retreat since starting treatment
with an experimental combination of
drugs the secondary tumor in a muscle
behind her bowel has halved in size and
she's feeling positive the last sort of
scans I had of that was back in April
and I've come back stable they've been
stable ever since about September last
year and originally the suez muscle
tumor one was nine millimeters and it's
gone down to four millimeters so yeah it
probably always still be there but you
know it shrunk it's wrong it done what
it said circulating antigen presenting
cells collect these tumor antigens and
present them to activate t-cells the
combination of two drugs appeal in the
map and nivolumab targets the
invisibility cloak that many cancers
used to hide from the immune system but
the tumor unveiled immune cells
recognize the threat and move in for the
kill in a new study of patients with
advanced melanoma more than half the
tumors shrank or stopped growing and
scans of a patient with advanced lung
cancer reveal how the chima almost
melted away in response to the drugs
study selected for asker's prestigious
speaking from a cancer conference in
Chicago one British doctor described the
breakthrough as the most exciting of his
career if we understand who to give them
to we can get the right drugs to the
right people at the right time with a
white tumor and really dramatically
increased the QA and if we can't cure
people will increase the proportion of
people living with cancer as opposed to
dying from it but if alima mab alone
costs 75,000 pounds for a year's
treatment the price of the other drug
has yet to be said one health think tank
warns the cost of new cancer drugs is so
high
it sucks NHS money away from other
diseases while in service will end up
getting cancer so we simply actually
cannot afford to pay for all these drugs
if we go on paying and they're hundreds
of thousands of pounds for end-of-life
cancer drugs so that's why we're calling
for a public debate about what we spend
the money on and what our priorities
should be but doctors have hailed
immunotherapy as the start of a new era
in cancer treatment it could even
replace Orthodox chemotherapy with all
its toxic side effects within five years
Thomas More Sky News more now on what's
being described as a major breakthrough
in cancer treatment with experts saying
trials of a powerful new combination of
drugs have achieved spectacular results
the drugs make the body's own immune
system attack cancerous cells Sky News
spoke to dr. Jed wallchuck chief medical
oncologists at New York's Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center who's
attending a cancer conference in Chicago
I was extremely gratified to see these
results because of course it meant a
significant step forward for our
patients but also because it meant
confirmation of smaller trial
observations that my group and others
made over the past two or three years
the particular difference in this trial
was the inclusion of a group of patients
who received two different
immunotherapies together each of the
each of the individual treatments is
currently available either as a standard
therapy or as an experimental of therapy
but the combination is only available
you know at in terms of a clinical trial
at the moment so the particular
combination tries to get the immune
system activated by removing two
molecular breaks that prevent the immune
system from seeing and responding to
cancer in a full manner I think what
this shows us is that depending upon the
particular characteristics of the
patient's tumor you know
up to seventy-two percent of patients
could have a significant regression with
the use of the combination therapy we
also saw that in some subsets the median
time to the tumor growing was 14 months
which is quite striking because just
five years ago the average life
expectancy for a patient with metastatic
melanoma was seven months so now we're
talking about 14 months you know median
time to when the cancer might start to
grow again I think we should be quite
excited about this this represents a
very significant step forward in our
quest to develop better treatments for
melanoma which as I said before just
five years ago the median survival was
seven months and now we're really seeing
very different sort of numbers which
gives tremendous hope to patients with
this disease and and further importantly
treatments like this are showing
activity and diseases other than
melanoma so what we learn studying this
disease we hope to apply widely to many
different kinds of cancer